einen schönen guten tag aus hagen und
herzlich willkommen zu dieser online
vorlesung in der ich mich mit der frage
beschäftigen möchte was soziologie
eigentlich ist womit sie sich
beschäftigt und wie soziologinnen und
soziologen das tun
in anderen worten möchte ich heute also
versuchen auf einer eher allgemein
gelegentlich vielleicht auch ein wenig
abstrakten ebene den
forschungsgegenstand der soziologie
ebenso herauszuarbeiten wie den
soziologischen denkt stil und tun möchte
ich das anhand zweier klassischer
konzepte ich möchte ihn so zwei sehr
prominente soziologische klassiker
vorstellen das ist nicht ganz zufällig
denn sie müssen wissen die soziologie
ist eine vergleichsweise klassiker
verliebte disziplin ja die also diese
texte die in ihrer gründerzeit der wende
vom 19 20 jahrhundert entstanden sind
bis heute stark wertschätzt und auch im
aktuellen soziologischen diskurs
hochhält
gelegentlich wird das freilich auch ein
wenig übertrieben ja also wenn
regelrechte exegese klassischer
soziologischer texte betrieben werden
aber den nach wie vor hohen stellenwert
soziologischer klassiker den kann ich
durchaus auch nachvollziehen wenn ich
sie lese bin ich nämlich immer wieder
verblüfft ob ihre aktualität ja heute
weisen diese alten texte also durchaus
noch eine hohe erklärungs kraft
aufwendet darum geht die gesellschaft in
der wir heute ja also wenn man so will
in der späten moderne leben erklären
und dass sie nach wie vor eine so hohe
erklärungs kraft haben es vielleicht
auch nicht ganz zufällig ja denn die
klassischen soziologischen texte sind ja
in einer zeit oder vor dem hintergrund
eines immensen gesellschaftlichen
wandels entstanden
eines wandels ja der die
lebensverhältnisse in unserer
gesellschaft in ganz nachhaltiger
grundlegender allenfalls in der weise
verändert hat ja vor dem hintergrund
einer great transformation vikar colani
das mal genannt hat und er meint damit
den wandel von der vormodernen agrar in
die moderne industriegesellschaft herren
mit dem also wirklich für alle menschen
eine ganz grundlegende veränderung ihrer
ihre lebensumstände und ihre
lebensweisen einhergegangen diesen
diesen grundlegenden wandel den hatten
die soziologischen klassiker vor augen
und die aktualität wird vermutlich daher
dass es einen solchen allumfassenden
wandel seither nicht mehr gegeben hat ja
also ganz aktuell sprechen kolleginnen
und kollegen davon dass wir vielleicht
gerade in diesem moment wieder in einer
ehrlichen zeit leben mehr ein der es
angesichts von automatisierungs
prozessen von digitalisierungsprozess
wieder zu einem ähnlich weit reichenden
wandel kommen könnte aber das ist
freilich erst im nachhinein
festzustellen
die beiden klassiker die ich ihnen heute
vorstellen würde möchte sind zwei sehr
prominente gründerväter der soziologe
max weber und eben hier dirk m
dass sich diese beiden ausgewählt habe
ist freilich nicht ganz zufällig schauen
sie doch auf recht unterschiedlichen
perspektiven auf die gesellschaft herrn
max weber vom einzelnen aus vom akteur
wie wir als soziologinnen und soziologen
gerne sagen ja und er fragt sich wie und
warum handelt dieser akteur und welche
folgen hat das für soziale phänomene für
gesellschaftliche strukturen und die
türkei wählt in gewisser weise den
umgekehrten weg
er ist kein handlungsträger es struktur
theoretiker und beginnt sein denken
deshalb bei gesellschaftlichen
strukturen und fragt danach welche
auswirkungen diese auf das handeln des
einzelnen akteurs
ja also zwei grundlegend verschiedene
perspektiven zwei zentrale pole des
soziologischen denkens die gelegentlich
auch als zwei verschiedene soziologie
bezeichnet wurden nämlich als die
sociology auf social action einerseits
und die soziologie of social structure
andererseits würde davor warnen diesen
unterschied zu überhöhen weil ich glaube
dass man beide perspektiven
berücksichtigen muss wenn man ein
konkretes soziales phänomen verstehen
will max weber und emil dürr kam also
auf die behalten komme ich gleich zurück
bevor ich sie ihnen vor stelle möchte
ich aber gerne mal versuchen ein paar
ganz allgemeine merkmale des
soziologischen denkens herauszuarbeiten
dass sich doch vielleicht in dem einen
oder anderen punkt unterscheidet von vom
alltags weltlichen denken ja
soziologisches denken und alltags
weltliches denken haben wir durchaus
auch eine nähe zueinander denn auch sie
gehen natürlich nicht durchs leben ohne
die soziale welt um sie herum zu
beobachten ohne zu versuchen sie zu
verstehen ohne zu fragen warum passiert
etwas warum entsteht etwas aber
vermutlich gehen sie anders vor als wir
versuchen das in der soziologie zu
machen wenn man diesen diesen besonderen
soziologischen denkst hier zu dem ich
sie durchaus einladen möchte er aber
manchmal versucht dessen merkmale heraus
zu arbeiten finde ich kann man das gut
mit vier postulaten tun die der kollege
uwe schimank mal beschrieben hat die
vier postulate des soziologischen
denkens china gesagt wenn man
soziologisch denken will ist es zunächst
wichtig nicht zu moralisieren
ja also nicht vorschnell zu versuchen
die dinge zu bewerten sondern es geht
darum dass auch ein begriff von max
weber die dinge wert urteils frei zu
analyse
ja und das ist ja ein großer unterschied
zum alltags weltlichen denken denn sie
wissen wenn sie in einer kneipe ich will
gar nicht sagen an einem stammtisch ja
aber wenn sie mit anderen menschen
zusammensetzen und über etwas sprechen
dann drängen einen diese alltags
weltlichen diskussionen ja doch sehr
schnell dazu eine eine meinung ja eine
einschätzung bestimmter themen zu
entwickeln und das geschieht vielleicht
ab und an ein wenig vorschnell weil man
noch gar nicht das phänomen über das man
spricht richtig durchdrungen hat ja und
da möchte ich sie wirklich einladen also
im sinne webers und im sinne schien
angst wer teils frei an die dinge
heranzugehen weil ich glaube dass man
damit noch mal eine ganz andere
analytische native erreichen kann als
wenn man vorschnell versucht dinge zu
bewerten also ich würde dafür plädieren
dass solch eine bewertung erst ganz am
ende eines analyse prozesses steht das
hat übrigens schon august kommt das ist
der franzose dem die soziologie ihren
namen verdankt in der ersten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts gesagt dass er
geschrieben hat die soziologie bewundert
nicht und sie verdammt nicht die
politischen ereignisse sondern sie sieht
in ihnen wie in jeder anderen
wissenschaft auch geschieht einfach
gegenstände der beobachtung
das finde ich interessant diesen
vergleich zu anderen wissenschaften denn
auch ein naturwissenschaftler ein
physiker und chemiker ja würde ja
zunächst nicht versuchen die
physikalischen und chemischen prozesse
die analysiert zu bewerten sondern er
würde zunächst mal versuchen sie zu
verstehen und das versuchen wir in der
soziologie auch zweites postulat des
soziologischen denkst jetzt wäre nicht
personalisieren
ja das ist ein unterschied zu anderen
wissenschaftlichen disziplinen wenn sie
zum beispiel mal an die medizin denken
dann geht es da natürlich am ende immer
darum das leben eines einzelnen eines
konkreten patienten zu lindern
in der rechtswissenschaft geht es darum
das handeln eines einzelnen
angeklagten zu bewerten in der
erziehungswissenschaft geht es darum den
lernerfolg einer einzelnen schülerin
sicherzustellen ja und dieser einzelne
diese vereinzelter akteur der ist im
regelfall nicht gegenstand der
soziologie sondern für einen soziologen
oder eine soziologin wird eigentlich
immer erst dann interessant wenn mehrere
akteure aufeinandertreffen haben wie wir
gerne sagen wenn sie miteinander in
interaktion treten und wenn daraus das
werden wir gleich mit wählbaren dürkheim
sehen bestimmte strukturen entstehen die
auf ihr handeln zurückwirken es geht
also seltenst um den einzelnen selbst
wenn ich eine 1 1 1 eine einzelfall
analyse mache ja und einen einzelnen
handelnden akteure beobachte selbst dann
würde es mir als soziologen ja darum
gehen aus dieser einzelfall beobachtung
ein eher allgemeines modell abzuleiten
also nach mustern zu suchen nach
ähnlichkeiten im handel in verschiedenen
akteure also ich habe im grundsatz er
eine struktur allis tische als eine
personalisierte analyse perspektive
dritter grundsatz des soziologischen
denkst als drittes postulat wäre nicht
zu simplifizieren ja denn man muss sagen
als soziologe und soziologin hat man es
mit unglaublich komplexen
untersuchungsgegenstände zu tun ja
vielleicht mit den komplexesten mit
denen man sich überhaupt beschäftigen
kann denn ich meine wir haben es
zunächst einmal mit menschen zu tun ja
also wir haben es einerseits mit körpern
zu tun in denen schon hoch komplexe
biologische physiologische vorgänge
vonstatten gehen
hinzu kommt dann diese ja auch für sich
genommen sehr komplexe kognitive
komponente des menschen also was
passiert dann noch in einem gehör im
jahr also schon das ist sehr komplex und
dann treffen von diesen körpern und
ihrer kognitiven überformung auch noch
mehrere aufeinander wenn ein soziologe
anfängt sich damit zu beschäftigen und
aus diesem aufeinandertreffen
verschiedener handeln
entsteht dann auch noch etwas was man
als im agents beschreibt ja also aus dem
handelnden zusammenwirken verschiedener
akteure entwickelt sich etwas was durch
das handeln der einzelnen akteure
eigentlich gar nicht mehr zu erklären
ist sondern was wir dürfen sagen würde
ein vom einzelnen unabhängiges
eigenleben führt ja darauf kommen wir
zurück also sagen wir werden es in der
soziologie nie zu tun haben mit
einfachen erklärungen wir werden es
schon gar nichts zu tun haben mit
monokausalen erklärungen und ich glaube
das ist ein großer unterschied zwischen
dem soziologischen und dem alltags
weltlichen denken ja also zum beispiel
auch dem denken in dem wir häufig in
massenmedien konfrontiert sind
ich habe früher mal beim radio
gearbeitet und mein chef hat damals
immer gesagt ja patrick du das über
alles reden nur nicht über 90 sekunden
und das ist ein grundsatz den ich für
medien an der einen oder anderen stelle
vielleicht nachvollziehen kann aber der
sicherlich sehr hinderlich wäre wenn man
versucht eine soziologische analyse
durchzuführen nicht simplifizieren also
und als letztes nicht spekulieren
ja wir haben sie in der soziologie
nichts zu tun mit etwas was man früher
mal sozialphilosophie genannt hat
sondern ich glaube all die erklärungen
all die modelle all die theorien die wir
als soziologen entwickeln wollen die
müssen stets beruhen auf einer eben wert
urteils freien analyse empirische
befunde ja also sie müssen auf daten
basieren daten die wir beispielsweise
durch befragung durch interviews durch
beobachtung in ganz systematischer in
ganz transparenter im ganz regel
geleiteter art und weise erhoben haben
dass also vielleicht so viel ganz
allgemeine merkmale des soziologischen
denkens wir bemühen uns darum nicht
vorschnell zu moralisieren nicht so
personalisieren nicht zu simplifizieren
und nicht zu spekulieren und ich sagte
es schon ich möchte sie gerne einladen
also wenn sie
wenn sie selbst ja ein bisschen sich mit
soziologie beschäftigen möchten dann
möchte ich sie dazu einladen dass sie
mal versuchen diese vier postulate zu
berücksichtigen und vielleicht merken
sie dann diesen effekt den ich sehr gut
kenne dass man damit noch mal auf eine
analyse ebene kommt die ein ganzes stück
tiefer geht als das bei alltags
weltlichen beobachtungen der welt der
fall ist und damit möchte ich ihnen
gerne den ersten soziologischen
klassiker vorstellen max weber nämlich
der vermutlich bis heute prominenteste
deutsche soziologe geboren im april 1864
in erfurt als ältestes von acht kindern
eines juristen und stadtrats ja damals
eines der ersten berufspolitiker die es
in deutschland überhaupt gab max weber
in seiner kindheit und jugend eher ein
sorgenkind der familie ja einerseits war
er häufig kränkelt andererseits
intellektuell sehr interessiert ja hatte
schon als jugendlicher schopenhauer
gelesen hatte kant gelesen hatte
sämtliche klassiker der antike gelesen
und selbst mal über sich gesagt ich bin
intellektuell früh in allem anderen aber
eher spät reif geworden
weber hat dann ab 1882 ganz im sinne
eines wir für die damalige zeit typisch
war im sinne eines universalgelehrten ja
verschiedene fächer studiert soziologie
gab es ja eben zu der zeit noch nicht
mehr hat rechtswissenschaft studiert
nationalökonomie und geschichte zunächst
in heidelberg und nach seinem
militärdienst dann auch in berlin und
göttingen hat dann 18 86 sein
juristisches staatsexamen abgelegt hat
drei jahre später im handelsrecht
promovierte mit einer arbeit über
historische handelsgesellschaften in
italien und da ran dann im jahr 1892
auch in seiner habilitation
angeschlossen
in der es um die römische
agrargeschichte und ihre juristische
bedeutung ging 18 93 dann hochzeit
mit seiner frau marianne im selben jahr
erste außerordentliche professur in
berlin ja mit nur 29 jahren schon im
jahr später aber einen ruf auf den
lehrstuhl für nationalökonomie nach
freiburg und im jahr 1896 dann professor
für nationalökonomie in heidelberg wo er
auch studiert hat also kurzum alles sei
aus nach einer ganz herausragenden glatt
laufenden akademischen karriere
aber dann kam ein großer bedeutsamer
auch folgenreicher schnitt in max webers
geografie eine tiefe krise in der er
gestürzt ist und zwar nach einem streit
mit seinem vater ja max weber hatte
seine familie besucht
da sind glaube ich sehr alte
familienkonflikte aus aufgebrochen er
hat sich mit seinem vater überworfen sie
sind im streit auseinandergegangen und
das tragische an dieser begebenheit ist
dass max webers vater kurz darauf ganz
überraschend auf eine reise verstorben
ist ohne ja dass max weber die chance
hatte sich mit ihr auszusprechen und gar
auszusuchen und das hat ihn in eine
tiefe krise gestürzt
er musste seine lehrtätigkeit 1897
aufgeben hat auch einige zeit in
verschiedenen psychiatrischen anstalten
verbringen müssen und es ist sicherlich
für max weber eine sehr tragische
begebenheit der regelrecht an
depressionen zu leiden
man kann sie aber in gewisser weise auch
lesen als ein glücksfall für die
soziologie
und zwar aus zwei gründen erstens hat
diese zwei jahrzehnte dauernde phase in
der max weber nicht gelehrt hat und
nicht an einer universität beschäftigt
war ihm zeit verschafft ja auch muse
verschafft ohne die glaube ich sein wie
wir gleich sehen werden sehr
umfangreiches werk nicht hätte entstehen
können und in der zeit der unterbrechung
seiner lehrtätigkeit hat er sich von
diesen eher juristischen und
ökonomischen fragen seines frühwerks
entwickelt hin zu fragen die man heute
als soziologische fragen bezeichnen
würde und so hat er im jahr 1909 mit
anderen zusammen zum beispiel die
deutsche gesellschaft für soziologie
gegründet und sich fortan selber ja als
soziologen bezeichnet max weber war auch
politisch engagiert also insbesondere im
kontext des ersten weltkriegs war
mitglied friedens delegation hat an den
verhandlungen zum vertrag von der sad
teilgenommen war gründungsmitglied der
deutschen demokratischen partei und hat
nach dem ersten weltkrieg an der
weimarer reichsverfassung mitgeschrieben
und war dann ab 1919 auch wieder in der
wissenschaft tätig nun eben als
soziologe zunächst probehalber im rahmen
einer lehrtätigkeit in wien und ab dem
jahr 1920 dann als professor für
gesellschaftswissenschaften in münchen
diese phase hat dann aber nicht mehr
lange gewehrt max weber noch im gleichen
jahr 1920 nämlich im juni an den folgen
einer lungenentzündung gestorben ist
recht überraschend im alter von nur 56
jahren
und wenn man jetzt einen blick wirft auf
diese sind wie gesagt recht umfangreiche
werk von max weber haben wir es in
diesem frühwerk eben zu tun mit seinen
qualifikations abgehalten ja die
historisch eher ökonomische juristisch
ausgelegt waren und mit einer dann
soeben in der phase der depression
beginnenden soziologischen phase er
seine erste genuin soziologische schrift
würde ich sagen stammt aus dem jahr 1904
einen aufsatz über
sozialwissenschaftlich erkenntnis und im
gleichen jahr veröffentlich dann eines
seiner hauptwerke vor allen dingen sein
für mich als religionssoziologen
interessant ist religion soziologisches
hauptwerke nämlich die protestantische
ethik und der geist des kapitalismus in
der er danach fragt was eigentlich die
idee allen grundlagen dafür sind ja dass
sich das sich in der moderne und gerade
in unserem jahr in unseren westlichen
gesellschaft der kapitalismus
herausbilden könnte
religion hat ihn sehr interessiert also
deswegen hat er auch dieses recht
epische werk diese dieser
aufsatzsammlung ja die wirtschaftsethik
der weltreligionen herausgegeben 11
aufsätze sind das glaube ich sehr
umfangreich und in diese soziologische
phase fallen dann beispielsweise auch
noch zwei recht prominente aufsätze ja
die bis heute häufig zitiert werden
nämlich wissenschaft als beruf also das
wird gerade so in akademischen kreisen
immer wieder gerne zitiert weil er zu
der zeit schon davon spricht dass mit
wissenschaft auch immer so eine gewisse
prekarität einhergeht und außerdem gibt
es diesen diesen schriftlichen vortrag
politik als beruf und dann kam der
überraschende der frühe tod von weber so
dass einige dinge posthum veröffentlicht
wurden ja federführend weil er
insbesondere seine frau marianne die
auch die vereine der bis heute
bedeutsamsten biographien über max weber
verfasst hat sie hat zum beispiel in
seinem namen auch recht prominenten
aufsatz über musik herausgegeben vor
allen dingen aber dann im jahr 1922
webers hauptwerke also ein opus magnum
mit dem titel wirtschaft und
gesellschaft
das wirklich ein sehr prominentes berg
das ist auch mal gewählt worden von von
soziologen und soziologin weltweit zum
bedeutendsten internationalen
soziologischen werk des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in das möchte ich in
gewisser weise mit ihnen jetzt auch
einen kleinen blick werfen ja da auch
das ist es ein sehr umfangreiches werk
aus dem ich jetzt aber nur mal ein
wirklich ein paar worte raus greifen
möchte worte die ganz am anfang stehen
und in denen weber seine recht legendäre
definition dessen was soziologie
formuliert ja ganz am anfang von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft in den
soziologischen grundbegriffen die weber
da erläutert schreibt also ich glaube
gleich auf der ersten seite soziologie
soll heißen eine wissenschaft welche
soziales handeln deuten verstehen und
dadurch in seinem ablauf und seinen
wirkung ursächlich erklären will
da steckt also eine ganze menge drin in
diesem wie gesagt wenigen worten zum
beispiel dieses für mich persönlich
recht wichtige wort des verstehens das
glaub ich am anfang auch schon mal das
eine oder andere mal verwendet habe ja
also es geht uns in der soziologie darum
bestimmte phänomene wert urteils frei
und tief zu analysieren um sie
tatsächlich verstehen zu koennen
und weber das ist ja wichtig
an diesem punkt denn sie müssen wissen
die soziologie gab es eben noch nicht
als eigenständige wissenschaft so dass
man erst mal sagen muss was was soll das
eigentlich sein ja also womit
beschäftigt sie sich und das bringt
weber auf einen bestimmten begriff
nämlich soziologie soll eine
wissenschaft sein die sich mit sozialem
handeln beschäftigt
ist man dieses soziale handeln der
zentrale begriff sozusagen bei weber
diese dieser frage was soziales handeln
ist muss man sich glaube ich in drei
schritten näher und so tut es auch weh
bei also zunächst mal muss man sich
fragen was ist handeln denn das ist
schon für weber etwas spezifisches dass
sich vom verhalten das wäre der erste
schritt unterscheidet ja also verhalten
ist für weber sozusagen jegliches tun ja
auch jegliches unterlassen jegliches
dulden eines menschen ja das ganz
innerlich stattfinden kann dass sich
auch nach außen richten kann ja und von
von dieser großen menge des verhaltens
gibt es eine kleine teilmenge des
handelns und weber sagt von handel kann
man immer dann sprechen wenn das
verhalten mit einem subjektiv gemeinden
sind verbunden ist
ja wenn der handeln der akteure mit
seinem handeln also eine bestimmte
intention ja eine bestimmte absicht eben
einen subjektiv gemeinden sinn verbindet
und ich glaube dabei ist wichtig zu
wissen dass es auch hier einen großen
unterschied zum alltags weltlichen
gebrauch des begriffs es gibt ja denn
wenn wir im alltag von sinn sprechen
dann meinen wir damit ja meist etwas
normatives ja wir sagen oh das ist aber
sinnvoll oder wir sagen hey das macht
doch gar keinen sinn
ja wir bewerten also häufig dinge wenn
wir von sinn sprechen
das ist aber nicht der weber schüssel
christa sondern weber geht es überhaupt
nicht darum wie gesagt von ihm stammt
dieser begriff der welt urteils freiheit
ja weber geht es überhaupt nicht darum
dinge zu bewerten sondern er will
herausarbeiten ja was der handeln der
akteure welchen sinn der seinem handeln
zugrunde gelegt hatten nehmen sie mal
ein beispiel stellen sie sich vor ich
würde diese online vorlesungen
halten indem ich mich auf den kopf
stelle ja dann würde man alltags
weltlich ja sagen würde das macht doch
gar keinen sinn also warum steht der
häuser da auf den kopf wenn eine
vorlesung hält ja aber das ist nicht was
frage sondern weber würde danach fragen
welchen subjektiven sind ich mit dieser
etwas seltsamen handlung verbinde dass
ich hier bei der vorlesung auf dem kopf
stehen
herr und er würde noch einen schritt
weitergehen vielleicht auch ein schritt
zurück weil es die grundlage dafür ist
ja er würde nämlich die these aufstellen
dass man diesen subjektiv gemeinden sind
nicht meinem handeln zugrunde lege
überhaupt rekonstruieren kann dass man
ihn verstehen kann ja sehr wichtige
grundlage also ohne diese annahme kann
ich soziologie eigentlich nicht
betreiben ja also wenn ich nicht die
annahme habe dass ich zum beispiel indem
ich ein interview führen oder indem ich
jemanden beobachte ja also dass ich
durch diese durch diese empirischen
daten herausarbeiten kann warum jemand
etwas gemacht habe also wenn die wenn
ich diese annahme nicht habe dann stoße
ich glaube ich schnell in der
soziologischen forschung an grenzen
ja und weber sagte aber natürlich
subjektiv gemeint sind kann
rekonstruiert werden
wörtlich sagt er man muss nicht caesar
sein um cesar zu verstehen
also eine sehr grundlegende annahme für
soziologische forschung die freilich
gewisse voraussetzungen hat oder auch an
grenzen stoßen kann also natürlich
vertrete ich diese these zunächst auch
in meiner eigenen forschung also wenn
ich als religionssoziologe ja
beispielsweise interviews führen mit
pilgern oder mit katholischen priestern
ja dann gehe ich natürlich auch davon
aus dass ich dadurch rekonstruieren kann
warum die gehandelt haben wie sie
gehandelt haben ja aber ich habe es
dabei eben auch
sozusagen mit interviewpartnern zu tun
mit denen ich dinge teile in der
soziologie sagt man gerne wo wir einen
geteilten sinn haben der
interviewpartner und ich sowie sprechen
beispielsweise die selbe sprache ja wir
kommen auch aus dem gleichen kulturkreis
und vielleicht verbinden mich auch noch
andere dinge wie das geschlecht oder das
alter oder der bildungsgrad mit meinen
interviewpartnern und dann kann ich
natürlich deren subjektiv gemeinden in
denen sie ihrem handeln zugrunde legen
rekonstruieren
anders würde es vermutlich aus schauen
ja wenn ich ein interview führen mit
jemandem aus einem völlig anderen
kulturkreis ja der auch eine ganz andere
sprache spricht er vielleicht ein
anderes geschlecht hat vielleicht ein
ganz anderes bildungsniveau hat ja also
an solchen punkten muss ich mich
natürlich schon fragen kann ich wirklich
subjektiv gemeinden sind rekonstruieren
im grundsatz würde ich mich da aber
weber anschließen und sagen jawohl das
ist möglich und dadurch können wir das
handeln eines akteurs tatsächlich auch
verstehen
ja das ist also handel verhalten dem ein
subjektiv gemeinde sind zugrunde liegt
dritter schritt wäre jetzt noch zu
fragen wann es handeln soziales handeln
weber sagt dass es immer dann der fall
wenn sich das handeln eines akteurs auf
einen anderen bezieht oder an ihm
orientiert also auch hier haben wir
einen anderen begriff des sozialen
als wir das in der alltagssprache häufig
haben also wenn wir im alltag von sozial
sprechen dann meinen wer häufig so etwas
wie soziale einrichtungen oder
sozialhilfe oder soziales engagement
also kurz ungemein so karitative sachen
ja wir meinen
wenn man normativ wenn man das normativ
sagen meinen wir irgendwie gute sachen
ja wenn wir sozial reden von sozial
reden das ist allerdings nicht webers
stoßrichtung mehr sondern für ines
handeln immer dann sozial wenn es sich
auf einen anderen bezieht ja also
stellen sie sich vor ich hätte hier
unterm pole tätig irgendwie eine keule
versteckt und ich würde jetzt hier im
studio unserer kamera frau die diese
keule über den kopf hauen
ja dann würden sie im alltag vermutlich
nicht von sozial reden sie würden
vielleicht sogar eher von asozial reden
aber für weber wäre auch dass soziales
handeln ja ich habe die keule der
kamerafrau über den kopf das ist
natürlich in seinem sinne soziales
handeln weil mein handeln sich auf sie
also auf eine andere bezieht ja und
dieses soziale handeln das kann
sozusagen in zwei richtungen sich auf
einen gegenüber beziehen nämlich
entweder reaktiv ja ich handle als eine
reaktion auf das handeln des anderen
oder es kann er antizipiert even
charakter haben ja das heißt ich handle
weil ich davon ausgehe dass der andere
daraufhin bestimmte art und weise
reagiert diesem punkt halte ich es für
wichtig dass man tatsächlich von
antizipation spricht weil mit luhmann
gesprochen
es ist natürlich höchst unwahrscheinlich
dass ich einschätzen kann wie ein
anderer auf mein handel reagiert das hat
vielleicht mit der frage zu tun in
welcher persönlichen beziehungen wird
zueinander stehen ja also je länger die
beziehung zu meinem gegenüber ist desto
größer ist natürlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass meine
antizipation mit der tatsächlichen
reaktion des anderen war einstimmen
sprich wenn wenn wenn ich jetzt meiner
frau zu hause blumen mitbringen
ja dann
dann ist natürlich die die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich den weiteren
verlauf des abends richtig einschätze
größer als wenn ich irgend jemand
wildfremden ein geschenk mache ja also
ich kann natürlich reaktion eines
gegenübers immer nur antizipieren und
das ist das ist im prinzip dieser
begriff webers der begriff des sozialen
handelns jahres handeln unterscheidet
sich vom verhalten durch den subjektiv
gemeinden sinn den ich rekonstruieren
kann und es wird dann zu sozialem
handeln wenn es sich auf andere reaktiv
oder antipathie iv bezieht und das ist
für ihn der forschungsgegenstand der
soziologie an dem punkt würde ich jetzt
allerdings noch einen schritt weiter
gehen wollen und zwar mit emile durkheim
weil er vielleicht auch noch die frage
ist also was aus diesem handeln
entstehen kann also insbesondere was
dann entsteht wenn ein auf ein gegenüber
bezogenes handel in wiederholter und
verstetigte art und weise vonstatten
gitter und das ist die frage
aus der mit der sich dirk m aus dieser
er strukturell ist ischen perspektive
beschäftigt zunächst auch noch ein paar
worte zu ihm hin ist mir immer wichtig
also ihnen auch ein bisschen über die
personen und die biografien der autoren
zu erzählen weil ich glaube dass man
texte ganz grundsätzlich nur dann
wirklich verstehen kann wenn man auch
ihre kontexte berücksichtigt also
insofern gerne auch zu emi dürkheim ein
paar stichworte in diesem fall ein
franzose auch einer der wirklich
prominenten und bedeuteten gründerväter
muss man ja sagen der soziologie 1858 in
lothringen geboren als jüngstes von fünf
kindern sohn eines rabbiners in ich
glaube achter
generation ja aber diese familien
tradition hat e mail dann nicht
aufgegriffen sondern sein denken
zeichnet sich eigentlich immer durch
eine eine eher religions- distanzierte
säkularität aus aufgewachsen ist dirk
heinen eher bescheidenen verhältnissen
ja also zumindest bis seine familie eine
nennenswerte erbschaft antreten konnte
und die schulzeit die lief zunächst
völlig problemlos also wenn man nicht
sogar sagen kann sie lief ideal dürkheim
hat sogar zwei klassen übersprungen
allerdings war seine jugend auch stark
geprägt von einem ereignis das ihn sehr
beeindruckt hat nämlich frankreichs
niederlage im preußisch französischen
krieg von 1870 71 über diese zeit hat
dirk einmal geschrieben alle guten
bürger war nur von einem gedanken
beseelt nämlich das land neu errichten
zu wollen und weiter eine demokratie
verrät die eigenen prinzipien wenn sie
nicht an die wissenschaft glaubte ja und
in diesem satz wird vielleicht eines der
grundanliegen von dirk m 's denken
deutlicher es ging ihm zeit seines
lebens darum eine moral zu entwickeln
ja eine moral die auf wissenschaftlichen
grundlagen beruht und die dazu in der
lage ist die gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten die dazu in der lage
ist integrativ zu wirken
darauf kommen wir gleich noch mal zurück
weil das weil das eine dezentralen
bergen fragen in türkis merck ist und
nach dieser problemlosen schulzeit
diesem beeindruckenden erlebnis des
preußisch französischen krieges ist
türkheim dann nach paris gegangen und
musste eine erfahrung machen die ihn
glaube ich auch stark beeindruckt hat er
wollte nämlich
der ecole normale superieure studieren
ja also dieser dieser intellektuellen
kaderschmiede frankreichs ja wenn man da
ein studium absolviert hatte stand ein
regelfall die tür zu professoren
laufbahn weit offen ja da wollte
dürkheim hin und war auch sehr
zuversichtlich angesichts dieser guten
schullaufbahn aber hat es dann zunächst
nicht geschafft erst im dritten anlauf
ist er an der ns aufgenommen wurden die
ersten beiden aufnahmeprüfungen hat er
also nicht bestanden habe dann ab 18 79
an deren es aber philosophie studieren
können harte schule ja also müssen sich
vorstellen die herren es zumindest zu
dieser zeit war als internat organisiert
er wurde im mehrbettzimmer eingeschlafen
da wurden die studierenden morgens um
sechs geweckt sie wurden den ganzen tag
beobachtet auch beim selbststudium das
gebäude verlassen dürfen sie nur am
sonntag ja also das war glaube ich nicht
ohne tageszeitungen waren verpönt ja
auch das was man nutzlose literatur
nannte war verpönt
so lernte dürkheim werden seines
philosophie studiums unter anderem die
schriften von august kommt kennen herr
sie erinnern sich
das ist der philosoph dem die soziologie
ihren namen zur verdient hat verdient
das studium verläuft auch erstmal gut ja
also die ersten beiden jahre schließt
dürkheim als jahrgangsbester ab den
dritten und macht so viel entscheidenden
den allerdings dann nur als siebter von
acht absolventen ja also keines
bildungsweg war eigentlich immer von so
einer wellenförmigen bewegung von einem
auf und ab von erfolgen und niederlagen
geprägt ja aber dann 1882 die
aggregation wie man das nannte also den
den abschluss des philosophie studiums
auf den zunächst mal der schuldienst
war typisch für die zeit also die
absolventen sind zunächst den
schuldienst gegangen und auch dürkheim
hat philosophie an verschiedenen
französischen gymnasien unterrichtet
etwas wozu er sich aber glaube ich nie
wirklich berufen fühlt deswegen hat er
schon in dieser zeit als rezensent
gearbeitet ja und rezensionen über
wissenschaftliche schriften geschrieben
was wiederum die voraussetzung war für
einen glücksfall im jahr 18 86
da bekam er nämlich kontakt ja heute
würde man sagen vielleicht zum
französischen wissenschaftsminister ja
damals hieß es leiter des höheren
unterrichtswesen ihn beauftragt hat nach
deutschland zu gehen und hier in
deutschland sollte dürkheim also im
auftrag des französischen ministeriums
den den stand dieser neuen
sozialwissenschaftlichen auch
soziologischen diskussionen
herausarbeiten und so ist nach leipzig
gegangen hat die experimental
psychologie von wilhelm wundt
kennengelernt ist nach berlin gegangen
hat den katheter sozialismus
kennengelernt und diese ermittlungen des
deutschen sozial wissenschaftlichen
diskurs ist ja die hat ihm dann
eigentlich die tür geöffnet für eine
akademische laufbahn und so hat er dann
1887 seine seine erste dozentur
angetreten und zwar in bordeaux ja das
war zunächst eine dozentur für pädagogik
soziologie gab es ja eben noch nicht ja
und
aber man wusste natürlich dieser
dürkheim wenn der jetzt zu uns nach
bordeaux kommt und hier seine
vorlesungen hält ja der beschäftigt sich
damit etwas ganz neuem der kennt sich
auch aus der war in deutschland den
interessiert das was man
verschiedentlich schon soziologie nennt
ja man muss wissen damals waren die
vorlesung öffentlich da waren viele
leute es gab immense erwartungen schnell
machte sich dürkheim in dieser zeit
einen namen als meister seines fachs
extrem arbeitsreiche zeit für ihn sehen
wir gleich bei einem blick auf sein werk
hat eine menge publiziert in dieser zeit
in porto und das hat auch früchte
getragen
1894 nämlich kam es zu einer umwidmung
der dozentur es war dann aber dann nicht
mehr dozent für pädagogik sondern ganz
offiziell dozent für soziologie der
erste dozent für soziologie in
frankreich überhaupt und das war ein
titel den türken der türken glaube ich
mit stolz erfüllt hat ja ebenfalls lang
gehegter traum der in erfüllung gegangen
ist dann 1902 nämlich der wechsel nach
paris sehr renommierte sorbonne auch
dabei zunächst lehrbeauftragte für
pädagogik ist dann 1906 zum ordentlichen
professor berufen worden hat 1912 dort
in paris sein opus magnum geschrieben
auch ein religion soziologisches buch
übrigens nämlich die elementaren formen
des religiösen lebens ganz interessantes
buch weil er sich auf sehr interessante
art und weise mit der frage beschäftigt
was eigentlich der kern ja was
eigentlich das wesen einer jeglichen
religion ist das hat ihn auch
international bekannt gemacht und 1913
wurde seine professur dann ähnlich wie
in bordeaux umgewidmet so dass er ab
dann der erste auch professor für
soziologie in frankreich war lief also
auch alles gut aber auch hier ähnlich
wie bei webern gab es einen einschnitt
nämlich den ersten weltkrieg
ja der zunächst einmal dazu führt dass
ab 1914 viele von le cams mitarbeitern
eingezogen wurden also dass er einige
seiner projekte einstellen musste zb ein
ein soziologisches jahrbuch dass er
schon lange raus gegeben hatte dass ihm
auch sehr am herzen lag ja das ist das
konnte nicht weitergeführt werden
angesichts des mitarbeiter mangels und
vor allen dingen wurde auch dirk heims
sohn andré eingezogen und ist dann ende
1915 im ersten weltkrieg gefallen was
dürkheim glaube ich sehr beeindruckt hat
was ihn sehr belastet hat er immer
gesagt schwermut wird der modus meines
restlichen lebens sein und dieser
schwermut hat dann vielleicht auch dazu
beigetragen dass auch dirk n früh
gestorben ist nämlich eben
november 1917 im alter von 59 jahren
das werk türkheims wie gesagt auch sehr
umfangreicher in dieser frühen phase in
der phase in bordeaux beispielsweise
seine zwei dissertation ja früher war
nicht früher war nicht alles besser
damals musste man nämlich zumindest in
frankreich noch zwei doktorarbeiten
schreiben und zwar eine auf latein
diese käme über monster skill
geschrieben und einer auf französisch
die hat dirk haben über soziale
arbeitsteilung geschrieben da möchte ich
gleich mit ihnen auch noch mal einen
kurzen blick reinwerfen weil die glaube
ich sehr
prototypisch ist für die fragen die
dürkheim in seinem frühwerk interessiert
haben nämlich wenn man so will sozial
strukturelle fragen ja also insbesondere
die frage danach was hält eigentlich
unsere gesellschaft gerade angesichts
dieser great transformation über die ich
eingangs sprach noch zusammen kommen wir
gleich drauf zurück zunächst der
vollständigkeit halber den gab es so
eine eher sagen wir mal publizistisch
ruhige zwischenphase in türkheims werk
und dann gab es eine interessante wende
von diesen
sozial strukturellen fragen nach dem
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft hin zu
eher kultur soziologischen fragen ja in
denen er sich beispielsweise eben mit
religion beschäftigt hatte ich sagte
schon 1912 die elementaren formen des
religiösen lebens und eine phase in der
er sich auch mit dieser frage nach der
wissenschaftlich begründeten moral
ja die eine gesellschaft zu integrieren
vermag beschäftigen wollte da gab es
schon konkrete pläne also geplant war
ein hauptwerk ein opus magnum mit dem
titel die moral zu dem es dann
allerdings aufgrund des frühen tods von
innen dürkheim nicht mehr gekommen ist
lassen sie uns also noch auf zwei
aspekte in türkis denken eingehen
nämlich zunächst auf diese frage nach
dem zusammenhalt der gesellschaft hat
diese frage diskutierte eben in seiner
französisch-sprachigen diskussion
dissertation über die soziale
arbeitsteilung und das hat stark damit
zu tun
mit dieser great transformation mit
diesen gesellschaftlichen wandel über
den ich eingangs sprach nämlich was
dürkheim beobachtet ist dass
gesellschaften immer arbeitsteiliger
werden das kann man ja heute noch sehen
wir haben heute immer spezialisierter
rufe ja also sozusagen ja in seinem
beruf beschäftigt man sich mit einem
immer spezifischeren fällt das heißt man
weiß sozusagen immer mehr über immer
weniger und damit einhergeht für
dürkheim so die überlegung ja wenn wir
alle so unterschiedliche berufe haben
wenn wir alle so unterschiedliche
lebenswelten haben wenn unsere moderne
gesellschaft so individualisiert
wenn sie so vielfältig wenn sie so
pluralisierten ist warum warum fällt sie
dann nicht auseinander was was hält sie
eigentlich zusammen und der antwort auf
diese frage möchte ich mich nähern indem
ich sozusagen mal in groben zügen
gesellschaftliche entwicklung
nachzeichnen ja ja und ich finde das
bietet sich an zu tun
aus der perspektive der theorie
funktionale differenzierung ja also das
ist etwas was nicht von e mail dürkheim
stammt sondern was in späterer zeit erst
entstanden ist
aber es ist glaube ich das was er meint
weil auch dirk heinz vergleichs folie
für die moderne gesellschaft sind früher
gesellschaftsform ja sind einfache sind
archaische gesellschaften in denen wir
es in der sprache der differenzierungs
theorie mit einer segment ehren
differenzierung zu tun haben ja also
diese frühen diese einfachen
gesellschaften die bestanden aus eben
ein nebeneinander relativ kleiner
sozialer einheiten
also wir hatten es zu tun mit einem
nebeneinander verschiedener clans
verschiedener stämme verschiedene dörfer
et cetera pp und das charakteristische
für diese sozialen einheiten für diese
klaren stimme und dörfer war dass alle
ihre mitglieder im wesentlichen die
gleichen sozialen rollen geraten
ja es gab in archaischen gesellschaften
kaum differenzierung ja es gab
vielleicht so etwas wie eine
differenzierung zwischen den
geschlechtern ja die einbahn eben jäger
die anderen waren sammler vielleicht gab
es auch mal so etwas wie ein
dorfältesten das war's dann aber im
prinzip schon ja ansonsten hatten alle
die gleichen sozialen rollen hatten die
gleichen lebenswirklichkeiten haben die
gleichen erfahrungen gemacht haben das
gleiche
haben das gleiche wissen geteilt ja also
ähnlichkeit ist etwas was das die
lebensverhältnisse der mitglieder dieser
sozialen einheiten beschreibt und
untereinander das verhältnis der
einheiten untereinander war dadurch
gekennzeichnet dass es sich um sehr
gleichartige einheiten handelt ja also
zwar unabhängig voneinander haben aber
doch die verschiedenen clans sehr
gleichartige lebensweisen entwickelt und
die einheiten bahnen gleichrangig er
hatte eine kleinstadt nicht über dem
anderen sondern es war eine existenz
nebeneinander und das änderte sich dann
grundlegend schon in den antiken
hochkulturen vor allerdings vor allem
allerdings in den feudalen
gesellschaften denn jetzt haben wir es
nicht mehr zu tun mit einer sekretärin
differenzierung sondern mit einer
strategie katholischen herz mit einer
hierarchie zu tun ja jetzt haben wir es
mit einer über- und unterordnung soziale
einheiten zu tun also zum beispiel mit
so etwas wie den schichten adel und
klerus bürgertum bauern besitzlose herr
die in einer hierarchie zueinander
stehen
das heißt diese sozialen einheiten sind
jetzt alles andere als gleichrangig ja
sondern adel und klerus stehen natürlich
ganz eindeutig über den bauern und sie
sind auch nicht mehr gleichartig sondern
ganz im gegenteil sehr ungleiche artig
können sie sich vorstellen also es macht
einen großen unterschied für die
lebensbedingungen
ob ich jetzt beispielsweise mitglied des
adels war oder ob ich ein bauer war und
wichtig ist
dass der einzelne ja dass das individuum
in diesen strategie katholisch
differenzierten gesellschaften mitglied
von nur einer einzigen einheit war dies
auch nicht verlassen konnte ja also
heute würde man sagen es gab zu der zeit
eigentlich keine soziale mobilität ja
also wenn ich bauer war hatte ich in
feudalen gesellschaften keine chance
mitglied des adels zu werden ja und ich
gehörte eben auch nur dem bauer thumann
und nicht gleichzeitig noch den bürger
tun oder ähnliches das individuum war
eine sozialen einheit zugeordnet und die
einheiten untereinander ungleich artig
und ungleich rang ich beides ändert sich
dann mit der moderne
denn heute leben wir so wird es
zumindest in der differenzierung theorie
beschrieben ja in einer funktional
differenzierten gesellschaft die besteht
aus einem nebeneinander verschiedener
gesellschaftlicher teilsysteme also um
nur ein paar beispiele zu nennen in
unseren gesellschaften gibt es ein
politisches system es gibt ein
wirtschaftssystem es gibt ein
bildungssystem es gibt ein medizinisches
system et cetera pp und was sie zum
beispiel bei niklas luhmann de
ausführlich nachlesen können ist dass
das besondere an diesen
gesellschaftlichen teilsystemen ist dass
sie sich in gewisser weise
verselbstständigen ja dass sie auch
relativ unabhängig von anderen teil
systemen funktionieren und ihre
spezifischen regeln und perspektiven
entwickeln da möchte ich nicht so tief
einsteigen aber ich glaube es ist für
die soziologie wichtig zu verstehen dass
es dass ein und derselbe gegenstand ja
sich aus den verschiedenen perspektiven
der einzelnen gesellschaftlichen
teilsystemen unterschiedlich darstellt
hallo man hat das selbst mal am beispiel
eines eines
zugunglück es veranschaulicht weil er
sagt ich habe also jetzt ein zugunglück
also ein icon das ein und dasselbe
ereignis das gestaltet sich oder stellt
sich aber völlig anders da je nachdem
aus welchem teil system ich gucke ja
also beispielsweise wenn ich im
wirtschaftssystem unterwegs bin und
jetzt sagen wir mal vorstandsvorsitzende
der bahn dann stellt sich dieses
zugunglück für mich in erster linie als
ökonomischer schaden daher als verlust
ja aus dem politischen system stellt
sich vielleicht die frage was an neuen
juristischen normen nötig ist damit
solche zugunglücke demnächst verhindert
werden ja aus sicht des medizin systems
also geht es darum den den beteiligten
den verletzten zu helfen aus sicht des
religions- systems geht es vielleicht
darum den hinterbliebenen seelsorge zu
leisten et cetera pp also ein und
derselbe gegenstand wird völlig anders
gedeutet je nachdem in welcher teil
system logik ich ihnen betrachte ja und
diese einzelnen tal systeme
untereinander ja die sind also sehr
ungleich sie gucken alle anders aber sie
sind prinzipiell gleichrangig also in
unserem modernen gesellschaften haben
wir es nicht mit einem teilsystem zu tun
was eine herausgehobene rolle in der
gesellschaft haben würde ja im gegensatz
zu früher wo das haben wir am klerus in
denen strategie katholisch
differenzierten gesellschaften gesehen
ja wo vielleicht als religion system
also so einen übergeordneten einfluss
auf sehr viele wird nicht alle
gesellschaftsbereiche hatte
das ist heute nicht der fall sondern
heute ist auch dass religion und system
eben nur noch ein spezifisches
teilsystem nebeneinander
es sind ungleich artige aber
gleichrangige teilsysteme und das
individuum ist bei der letzte punkt zu
der folie
das individuum ist jetzt nicht mehr wie
es früher war ja nur noch einer sozialen
einheit nur noch einem teilsystem
zugeordnet in gänze ja sondern ss
ausschnittsweise mehreren system
zuzuordnen
die man ist auch klar jetzt gerade
erhalte ich hier eine vorlesung ja das
heißt ich bewege mich im bildungssystem
ja ich bin als dozent tätig danach gehe
ich vielleicht in die mensa und kaufe
mir was zu essen dann bin ich als kunde
ein wirtschaftssystem tätig ja dann gehe
ich sonntag vielleicht in die kirche
dann bin ich als gläubiger im religions-
system unterwegs sein wenn europawahl
ist dann bin ich als wähler im
politischen system unterwegs ja also das
heißt ich bin immer in mehrere teile
system involviert aber nicht mehr
vollumfänglich nicht als ganze person
sondern nur ausschnitte von mir herrn
sind nämlich wenn man genauer schaut
sind es rollen ja die ich innerhalb
eines systems einnehmen also
beispielsweise wo ich jetzt diese
vorlesung halte er ist traurig dass
vielleicht ist ja gar nicht von
entscheidender bedeutung dass genau ich
als person als patrick kaiser diese
vorlesung halten sondern was für das
system bildung wichtig ist dass
irgendjemand ja der vielleicht ein
bisschen ahnung von soziologie hat diese
diese rolle einnimmt die rolle des
dozenten der diese vorlesung hält ja es
ist also nur ein bestimmter ausschnitt
von mir
der für das bildungssystem und für diese
vorlesung hier relevant gemacht wird
deswegen spricht nicole bezahlen auch
von der multiplen partial inklusion die
für moderne gesellschaften typisches und
das sieht wenn auch nicht expressis
verbis dürkheim auch so ja also er sieht
auch diesen unterschied zwischen den
einfachen gesellschaften
und der kompletten integration des
individuums und den ähnlichen
lebensbedingungen und dieser modernen
ausdifferenzierten gesellschaft mit
verschiedenen teilsysteme und wie er das
sagen würde
mit ganz unterschiedlichen berufs rollen
und lebenswirklichkeiten und fragt sich
jetzt eben wenn das so ist wenn das
pluraler wird in der moderne
was hält gesellschafter noch zusammen
früher sagt er war das einfach in diesen
klaren es gab halt diese großen
ähnlichkeiten in der lebensbedingungen
es gab eine direkte integration dadurch
dass alle die gleichen erfahrungen
gemacht haben das gleiche wissen geteilt
hat hat sich etwas entwickelt was
dürkheim kollektiv bewusstsein nennt und
er sagt daraus ergibt sich der
zusammenhalt oder wie er das nennt die
solidarität innerhalb der gesellschaft
ganz automatisch sie ergibt sich
mechanisch herr dürkheim sagt für
einfache für arabische gesellschaften
ist eine mechanische solidarität typisch
in der moderne dann aber mit
funktionalen differenzierung den großen
system den unterschieden in den
lebenswirklichkeiten kann sich
solidarität nicht mehr automatisch
entwickeln sondern wir haben eben ganz
unterschiedliche rufe ganz
unterschiedlichen lebenswirklichkeiten
und dürkheim benutzt jetzt eine analogie
aus der biologie
die einzelnen berufe stellte sich
nämlich vor
gleichsam wie die organe eines körpers
ja also natürlich macht innerhalb des
körpers ja das herz etwas völlig anderes
als die leber aber wichtig ist ja dass
das herz nicht ohne die leber existieren
kann und umgekehrt natürlich auch nicht
mehr und dürkheim sagt in gesellschaften
in modernen gesellschaften ist es auch
so na ja also wir haben natürlich die
verschiedenen berufsgruppen und
entschuldigen sie wenn ich ein bisschen
platt reden der 1
der bäcker backt brötchen und der
metzger macht wo es dabei das besondere
an den modernen gesellschaften ist dass
der metzger heute kein brot mehr backen
kann und dass der bäcker keine wurst
machen kann und deswegen wissen die
beiden
ja dass sie sozusagen aufeinander
angewiesen sind
ja sie sind spezialisiert auf ihr
jeweiliges aber sie brauchen einander
weil der einheit auch brötchen essen und
herren wo es testen möchte platt
gesprochen also die berufe sind wie
organe
die gesellschaft ist wie der körper und
der zusammenhalt der gesellschaft ergibt
sich gerade durch die spezialisierung
und durch die wechselseitige
abhängigkeit dass jede berufsgruppe auf
die andere berufsgruppe angewiesen ist
damit die gesellschaft als ganzes
funktionieren kann
das ist also die frage nach dem
zusammenhalt moderner gesellschaften die
sich dürkheim in seinem frühwerk stellt
und hier eben dieser organischen
solidarität beantwortet und als letztes
möchte ich jetzt noch auf ein konzept
von dürkheim eingehen dass er sozusagen
entwickelt um den forschungsgegenstand
des soziologie zu beschreiben deshalb
auch von ihm ein paar worte diesmal
seiner antrittsvorlesung in bordeaux 18
ganz ähnlich wie weber ja geht es auch
dürkheim darum die soziologie als
eigenständige wissenschaftliche
disziplin zu etablieren noch gibt es ja
nicht nur deswegen muss auch er zunächst
definieren was soziologie für ihn sein
sondern und er macht es im prinzip in
dem er die beiden dinge benennt die eine
jegliche wissenschaft braucht ja mich
eine wissenschaft braucht einen
spezifischen gegenstand ja mit dem sie
sich beschäftigt und sie braucht eine
spezifische methodik es war eine art und
weise wie sie sich mit dem gegner stand
beschäftigt beides benennt dürkheim
kumuliert in diesem recht berühmten satz
wo er sagt die soziologie hat einen
ausreichend definierten gegenstand und
eine methode ihn zu studieren
der gegenstand das sind die sozialen
tatsachen die methode ist die
beobachtung und das indirekte
experimentieren mit anderen worten die
vergleichende methode
letzteres lassen wir mal außen vor also
sein untersuchungsgegenstand ist jetzt
nicht das soziale handeln dass es bei
weber war sondern es sind soziale
tatsachen was meint er damit
ja wenn wir uns das mal ganz schematisch
vorstellen dann ist ja sozusagen der
einfachste fall mit dem man sich als
soziologe oder soziologen beschäftigen
kann immer eine dia de
ja also eine konstellation von zwei
individuen sagte schon der einzelne
interessierten soziologen eigentlich
immer nicht sondern interessant wird es
eigentlich erst ab dem punkt wo
mindestens zwei individuen
aufeinandertreffen im regelfall ist ja
noch viel mehr aber ebenso nötig ist der
einfachste fall und deswegen möchte ich
bei dem mal beginnen wenn wir uns das
vorstellen also wir haben eine
konstellation von zwei individuen die ja
das muss man auch als soziologe
vermutlich annehmen die in gewisser
weise getrieben sind durch etwas
individuelles ja durch eine bestimmte
motivation eben durch seine intention
und hbb sagen würde so durch so ein
subjektiv gemeinden sinn der ihr handeln
anleitet ja ich sage das deshalb so dass
man das annehmen muss weil das eben
nicht der gegenstand der soziologie ist
ja also für einen soziologen oder eine
soziologin ist ein individuum ja immer
sozusagen eine blackbox ja also was da
drinnen passiert in dem individuum das
kann ich mit den mitteln soziologie der
soziologie nicht sehen sondern mich
interessiert quasi das was hinten raus
kommt ja also mich interessiert das
handeln des individuums insbesondere
dann wenn es eben aufeinander bezogenes
weber würde sagen wenn das soziales
handeln ist oder etwas neu
soziologischer würde man sagen wenn es
sich um eine interaktion handelt und
wenn so eine interaktion ein
wiederholter art und weise ja
verstetigte art und weise vorkommt dann
entsteht genau das bad dürkheim mit
sozialen tatsachen meint ja dann
entsteht nämlich etwas was ich lös vom
sozialen handeln der beiden beteiligten
individuum und was wie dürkheim sagen
würde jetzt ein vom individuum
unabhängiges eigenleben entwickelt jetzt
gucken wir es gleich noch anhand eines
beispiels an aber lassen sie mich vorher
sagen dass das spannende an diesen
sozialen tatsachen die aus dem
handelnden zusammenwirken von individuen
entstehen ist dass sie dann auf die
individuen zurückwirken und dass sie
dabei in sehr grundlegender häufig auch
latenter art und weise auch die
motivation beeinflussen die dem
individuellen handeln zugrunde liegt und
das ist wenn sie mich fragen spannender
punkt weil er in gewisser weise die
frage nach dem freien willen berührt es
wird ja häufig diskutiert also gibt es
so etwas eigentlich wie ein freien will
ich würde zunächst darauf antworten na
klar
naja also wenn sie sich noch mal
vorstellen dass wir heute abend in die
kneipe gehen dann können sie natürlich
entscheiden was sie da trinken trinke
ich jetzt ein bier oder trinken wein
oder trinke ich im wasser es ist
natürlich gerade in unserer modernen
gesellschaft in der wir sehr frei
gesetzt sind von sozialen zwängen also
einerseits ihre völlig freie
entscheidung aber unterschätzen sie
nicht dass sie in einer gesellschaft
leben
eine gesellschaft in der sie in diese
hinein sozialisiert wurden schon ab
ihrer kindheit anja also unterschätzen
sie nicht den einfluss zum beispiel
denen ihr elternhaus hat ja was boote
dort getrunken
ja war das ein soziales umfeld in dem er
bier getrunken wurde
indem er wein getrunken wurde in dem
vielleicht das eine als
distinktionsmerkmal
herangezogen wurde ja also um gottes
willen man darf doch kein bier trinken
das ist was für bestimmte kreise oder
indem man gesagt hat nein bei uns gibt
es keinen alkohol oder unterschätzen sie
nicht diese sozialisations effekte
unterschätzen sie nicht dass sie
vielleicht schon zehn jahre mitglied
eines eines fußballclubs sind und dass
sie deswegen gar nicht auf die idee
kommen am samstag im stadion wein zu
trinken
ja weil es nicht cit ist weil es nicht
soziale tatsache ist würde dürkheim
sagen dass man in einem fußballstadion
wein trinkt ja ich will also sagen na
klar es gibt so etwas wie einen freien
willen sie können sich heute abend in
der kneipe selbst entscheiden aber der
raum der optionen was ihnen überhaupt
denkbar erscheint in einer kneipe zu
trinken in einem fußballstadion zu
trinken was ihm überhaupt schmeckt der
ist doch wenn sie mich fragen nicht
unwesentlich beeinflusst durch soziale
einflüsse wirken würde sagen durch
soziale tatsachen die beschreibt er dann
noch ein bisschen näher anhand von vier
merkmalen die ich zunächst mal ein
allgemeiner art und weise erläutern
würde und dann anhand eines beispiels ja
sozialetat zu haben für dürr kam also
vier merkmale zunächst sind sie
äußerlich ja also sie existieren
außerhalb des individuellen bewusstseins
und sie deshalb auch nicht durch andere
wissenschaften wie die biologie oder die
psychologie erklärbar sondern sie
existieren irgendwo in der gesellschaft
und werden durch sozialisation erworben
zweitens gehen soziale tatsachen mit
einem gewissen zwang her ja mit einer
gebieterischen macht mit einem
verhalten steuern den druck wieder
gesagt sie haben eine integrative
charakter schreibt der der sehr
unterschiedlich sein kann ja dieser
zwang kann einerseits bedeuten dass der
verstoß gegen eine soziale tatsache
sanktioniert wird
das ist vielleicht glauben eine
juristische enorm handelt man wird
bestraft wenn man wenn man nicht im
rahmen des sozialen tatsache handelt es
kann sich allerdings auch erwiesen um so
gepflogenheiten wie den weinen oder das
bier im fußballstadion handeln ja wo was
jetzt keine juristische normen sondern
eher so eine umgangsform ist drittes
merkmal sozialer tatsachen ist ihre
allgemeinheit ja das heißt soziale
tatsachen sind nicht universell
ja das heißt es gibt sie nicht überall
und zu allen zeiten ja eine soziale
tatsache hat nicht schon immer existiert
und würde in allen gesellschaften auf
der ganzen welt existieren so ist es
nicht sondern soziale tatsachen beziehen
sich auf eine bestimmte gesellschaft an
einem bestimmten ort auch das gleich am
beispiel aber zunächst noch das vierte
merkmal ja dass ich sozusagen schon
beschrieben habe ja das spannende an den
sozialen tatsachen ist auch dass sie
unabhängig sind unabhängig von
individuellen manifestationen dass sie
durch den einzelnen nicht verändert
werden können und er kann selbst der
benennt nun ein sehr breites spektrum an
sozialen tatsachen
er beginnt also bei sehr strukturierten
dingen wie rechtsnormen ja und endet bei
der flüchtigen phänomen wie sittlichen
geboten sprichwörtern bestimmten
geschmacks regeln und ich finde ein
beispiel anhand dessen sich das immer
gut erläutern lässt mit den sozialen
tatsachen ist das händeschütteln ja also
diese diese geste dass ich jemandem zur
begrüßung die hand geben wenn sie sich
das mal als soziale tatsache vorstellen
dann wird erstens glaube ich sehr
deutlich händeschütteln ist nichts was
was im individuum von vornherein
verankert wäre es kann ich ihnen
versichern als vater zweier kleiner
töchter kann ich ihnen sagen
die wussten nicht qua geburt dass man
jemand anderen die hand gibt man ihnen
begrüßt sondern ich muss ihnen das
beibringen sie werden also von mir
sozialisiert und übernehmen diese
soziale tatsache des händeschüttelns und
irgendwann wird es für sie ganz
selbstverständlich sein dass wenn sie
jemanden treffen den grüßen bei
demjenigen die hand geben händeschütteln
als soziale tatsache geht dann auch mit
einem gewissen zwang einher
ja also weniger so im sinne einer
juristischen norm die mit sanktionen
belegt wäre also in grenzfällen gibt es
auch dass sie erinnern sich vielleicht
an fälle in denen von gerüsten
diskutiert wurde ob ein muslimischer
vater einer weiblichen lehrerin die hand
geben darf und muss ja also das mag auch
vorkommen aber in erster linie ist es ja
ein sittliches gebot dass ich jemandem
zu begrüßung die hand geben können sich
ausprobieren wenn das nächste mal jemand
auf sie zukommt in die hand
entgegenstreckt denn er wieder die gäste
einfach mal nicht und dann werden sie
diesen zwang den dörfern da meint diesen
imperativen charakter spüren ja also
weil sie so etwas spüren würden wie
meditation vielleicht vielleicht auch so
etwas wie verachtung und händeschütteln
des allgemeinen ja das gibt es bei uns
und das ist ganz selbstverständlich
sagen wir mal in mittel und westeuropa
es ist ist es verbreitet das hat aber
noch nicht immer gegeben also nicht zu
jeder zeit sondern ist es spezifisch für
unsere epoche
und es ist eben spezifisch für einen
bestimmten sozialen raum ja also wenn
schon wenn sie nach südeuropa gucken da
verliert das händeschütteln als
begrüßungsgeld bedeutungen zu gunsten
von umarmung und küsschen oder wenn sie
an japan denken dass das händische
völlig unbekannt zugunsten der
verbeugung ja also man könnte vielleicht
sagen dass die existenz einer begrüßung
geste ein universales phänomen ist die
spezifische ausprägung der sozialen
tatsache händeschütteln aber die ist
allgemein für eine bestimmte
gesellschaft zu einer bestimmten zeit an
einem bestimmten ort und für jede
soziale tatsache ist auch das
händeschütteln unabhängig vom individuum
ja also auch wenn sie sich überlegen ich
finde es doof
mit dieser begrüßungs geste ich würde
gerne verändern und eine andere
begrüßungs geste einführen dann wird
ihnen das nicht leicht gelingen denn
diese sozialen tatsachen haben einen
eben sehr unabhängiges auch relativ
veränderungs resistentes eigenleben
das ist natürlich nicht heißt dass sie
sich nicht vor einem ganz im gegenteil
soziale tatsachen verändern sich aber
nicht durch unmittelbaren individuellen
einfluss und auch nicht schnell sondern
das sind eher langsame wandlungsprozesse
das also diese beiden klassischen
konzepte die sich mit der frage
beschäftigen was eigentlich der
forschungsgegenstand der soziologie ist
das soziale handeln von max weber die
sozialen tatsachen von e mail türkheim
möchte noch mal kurz zusammenfassen
eingangs dieser vorlesung habe ich
versucht ihnen ein paar allgemeine
merkmale des soziologischen denkens zu
umreißen zu denen ich sie gerne einladen
wollte ja wir bemühen uns als soziologin
unsere zu gelogen
darum nicht zu moralisieren sondern wert
urteils frei zu forschen
wir bemühen uns nicht zu personalisieren
sondern eher aus einer strukturell ist
ischen perspektive zu schauen welche
strukturen ergeben sich aus dem handel
mit zusammenwirken von akteuren und wie
wirken diese strukturen auf das handeln
zurück wir können nicht simplifizieren
weil wir es mit einem sehr komplexen
untersuchungsgegenstand zu tun haben
und wir bemühen uns darum nicht zu
spekulieren sondern unsere unsere
konzepte unsere modelle unsere theorien
auf der basis empirischer daten zu
entwickeln
dann habe ich ihnen von max weber
erzählt den prominentesten deutschen
soziologen und seinem konzept des
sozialen handelns ja also handeln als
ein bestimmtes verhalten eines akteurs
das mit einem durchaus rekonstruieren
subjektiv gemeinden sinn verbunden ist
und soziales handeln als spezial form
des handelns dass immer dann vorliegt
wenn das handeln eines akteurs auf
andere bezogen und an ihnen orientiert
ist und die sozialen tatsachen von e
mail dörfern die sich eben durch
äußerlichkeit zwang allgemeinheit und
unabhängigkeit auszeichnen und damit
hoffe ich dass ich ihnen einen kleinen
einblick geben da reingeben konnte womit
wir uns als soziologen und soziologin
eigentlich beschäftigen und liebe dabei
so denken und danken für die
aufmerksamkeit